I know like three women that have kept
their last name Beyonce's beyonce
knowles carter now did not Beyonce
Carter so I think the train is already
already started to change
I think there is a power dynamic that
exists when one person takes on the
other person's name we need to take
someone else's last name so that he
whose commitment to that person I'm a
traditionalist I would take my husband's
last name the prospect of like coming up
with the name together is really cool
just creating an identity together is
really neat I like hyphenating I know
it's like weird I love my last name if I
were to marry a man or a woman I would
keep my last name
please imagine the following you have
been invited by an old friend to an
outdoor potluck picnic in the park when
you arrive you say hello to your friend
add the donuts you brought to the large
array of food and then settled down on a
big blanket to eat and hang out as soon
as you sit down you meet a couple who
was sitting next to you Michael
Robertson and his wife Carla Robertson
Michael Robertson and his wife Carla
Williams she kept her last name when
they got married they have been together
for three years and married for one as
you chat with them you learn more about
their lives Michael tells me buzz epic
on even when they took Carla shows you
pictures of their two dogs Michael
explains his job to Carla share stories
from their experience volunteering for
local events
so Carla Robertson caring I gave her a
six intelligent for ambitious three
caring I put five Carlo was the one who
showed pictures of their dogs to me it
came off more like she was the carrying
one assertive I put three independent
three quiet for list three jobs that you
think Carl Robertson might have I
originally put down unemployed because
she talked about volunteer work the
first thing I said was nurse because I
said over here that she was really
caring HR receptionist and then interior
design I don't know she seems artistic
maybe to how much money would you
estimate Carla Robertson makes her year
zero to forty K per year I put seventy
thousand dollars
$55,000 koala Williams intelligent six
ambitious six ambitious five ambitious
six assertive six assertive six
independent six confident six
independent six it's gotta be a pretty
confident and independent to like want
to keep her name's to go in the face of
societal norms that way
independent six quiet one list three
jobs do you think Carla Williams might
have I feel like they're professional
couple I said CEO I'd she just seemed
like she's just about her business but
yet she's still a loving wife and you
can have both worlds businesswoman
politics or professor engineer involved
in advertising or an accountant our
professor how much money would you
estimate Carla Williams makes per year
seven DK eighty thousand per year
seventy five thousand 75k
like our subconscious perceptions of
things are so crazy and we don't even
realize that we're making these
judgments on people when ever hear of
the wife taking the husband's name or
the wife keeping her name or the husband
taking the wife's name I do
instantly make assumptions as to who
would be wearing the pants in the
relationship so the fact that these two
characters kept their last names was
really cool collect the marriage didn't
define them they were still their own
individuals they were just in it
together
I think it's cool my wife wanted to keep
her last name I think they'd be awesome
if my sister were to keep her last name
I'd be like you go girl when I meet a
woman who's kept her last name I just
assumed that she's just a boss I like to
think of myself as like a strong
independent lady and I'm not taking
anybody's last name but my own I don't
think you should be judged by if you
change your last name to someone else's
last name it's not your life like it's
it's somebody else's life it just be or
about ourselves and it's okay if you're
mr. Robertson or mrs. Jeong or whoever
you do you